[Music]
this is star talk
cosmic queries edition for my co-host
today i've got the one the only
the inimitable
the uh
she's so unique in this world i don't
think anyone is related to him
jordan clipper
jordan
no i have no close relatives a very few
close friends
there was an egg somewhere and you
hatched out of it that's that's i i was
born into this earth who knows from
where and who knows what would come from
me but here i am yeah i mean i just you
know i first as for so many people i was
introduced to your work uh on comedy
central as a sort of correspondent
running around the country
exploring the depths of irrationality
that has befallen
us all and i think i keep thinking to
myself
if he weren't doing this
who would and like no one right so so i
just want to thank you for all of you
have done to expose the underbelly of
the country this is i feel like i'm like
james cameron diving into the abyss
but it's not underwater it's just into
the heartland of america the heartland
of america so we've got you for
a cosmic aquarius and this is a grab bag
edition so i you know we don't like to
admit it but every now and then there's
just like the leftovers from from all
from all the leftovers because they
didn't fit a category they didn't fit a
theme and so here they are
like the trash bin of questions doesn't
mean we don't love the questions it just
meant they didn't find a place before
today yeah to be clear for all of those
folks who are out there you're not
second tier you're just such unique
thinkers you you can't be categorized
other things other than the category of
trash bin
with that like a badge about a trashy
badge about exactly
all right so you have all the questions
and i haven't seen them yet not that
we're trying to stump me but if i don't
know the answer i'll just say i don't
know and we move on
and i love knowing where the people came
from if they if it happens to be in
their in their signature
and these are all from our patreon
supporters so patreons uh we changed the
rules so they're the only ones who
actually get to ask questions for
cosmic queries so those are the rules
and to be to be clear
i know it's not the goal but i do hope
they stump you just because
[ __ ] nail your cocky and it's important
to knock you down a peg uh for me it
makes me feel better about myself so i'm
really rooting against you on this one
just before you begin there was a uh
because people like trying to you know
stump you it's they won't even try to
not stump you if they could they'll put
in extra energy to stop so so i once
tweeted
that
um
i i once tweeted that a plane whose
engine fails
is a glider
a helicopter whose engine fails is a
brick
so i thought it's pretty clear what i'm
talking about there but no
okay
it's it's so
so apparently helicopter experts
jumped in and said no the engine can
fail
but the propellers will still turn
okay and then you have something called
auto rotation where you can kind of
guide
your fall from the sky you know like the
little uh the seeds that can um that
fall off the tree that have little
propeller blades yeah they don't just
fall straight to the ground they they
have a controlled descent and so no one
no one volunteered to say
maybe neil meant there's no upward lift
at all okay
an engine failure
along with the propeller failure right
no one volunteered that possibility as
to what i might have been intending and
so they all just said we're going to
prove neil wrong he's wrong he's so
okay okay this is how it is
what's the first one you have let's jump
into sandra sandra pagliani has a
question
uh she says first of all she says woohoo
what a thrill to be on patreon thank you
sandra
uh she says i've been diving into
multiple books on the multiverse and i'm
still struggling with the string theory
concept could you please explain it in a
simple way or write a string theory book
for dummies so i finally got it
well so a great book on this which was a
big bestseller was from my friend and
colleague brian greene he wrote a book
called the elegant universe and there's
a lot of other stuff in there but he's a
string theorist and so string theory
deeply infuses
his writings because that's the side of
the fence he's on as he comes to the
topic so
what i can do is tell you that we have
quantum physics
right
that's the theory of the small so that
gives us an understanding of
molecules and atoms and particles and
then we have einstein's general theory
of relativity which is explains the
entire
universe what gravity is doing to shape
the universe and out of that we get the
big bang and black holes and all and all
manner of other things
but it turns out
if you take einstein's general theory of
relativity and apply it all the way down
to the center of a black hole where we
call it singularity it blows up
i mean not literally it mathematically
blows up do you remember when you took
math in like high school you weren't
allowed to divide by zero
right you know
okay it's kind of like that the man was
holding me down that's how i always saw
that's how you felt about it yeah how i
felt you wanted to do it just somebody
was in your way right you don't tell me
what to do mr forrester
so
so we know general rel theory of
relativity has limits
all right it applies in all these
large-scale places but when you get down
to these tiny areas it doesn't
now so here's the problem
at the big bang because general
relatively takes us like from the big
bang onward but right at the point of
the big bang when the universe was
really small
wait a minute
if the universe was once small
then maybe quantum physics applies to
the entire universe
in those few moments
so you have a shotgun marriage of these
two
highly successful theories of the
universe but we don't know how to do
that
strength theorists have come in and said
we have an umbrella that will enclose
them both
and put them under one coherent
understanding of how the universe works
and we get the singularities out of it
we get quantum physics and we get
general relativity
so that's my sort of overview of what
strength theorists are trying to
accomplish here but they haven't really
yet and it's been a lot of them working
for decades and i've gone up to them and
i say how come you're not there yet i've
been waiting around they've been at this
basically since the early 80s and
there's like dozens of them right maybe
even scores of them is how can we have
another he said well it's hard
so then i said to brian greene to his
face i said could it be
that you are all just too stupid
why is it that it's hard and you're not
smart enough right it's not that you're
not smart enough why what's going on
there of course no uh cosmologist
theorist physicist is gonna say i'm
stupid they'll say the problem is hard i
i take a a different sort of view i
think maybe there's yet another place to
explore
for uh for this umbrella and maybe it's
not string theory i don't know
but that's where we are now this these
two are still not married
well i mean
marriage marriage equality even in the
galaxy in and of itself is a process i
think we've american political system
says it's not that it can't happen it
happens slower than we want it yeah
that's what it is it's happening slower
than we than we really want exactly yeah
exactly um this is from scott w peterson
in this month's national geographic
there's an article about our
investigation of small solar system
objects
in it there's a little discussion about
the formation of the solar system the
theory is that jupiter formed closer to
the sun and when it moved outward it
affected the orbits of outer icier
objects thus hurling them toward earth
this bombardment was where we got water
from white couldn't have been the
opposite the earth formed out
out there where there is more ice than
was catapulted inward to a point where
the ice becomes liquid
oh
very nice question
i love it when people read and think
and and this is good
this is a thoughtful audience and
they're magazine subscribers
and that means they read they read
it's print is not dead it's alive it's
coming to this man's house i bet this
guy i gotta believe scott i believe has
that beautiful wall of yellow national
geographic oh yeah everybody does yeah
the old rectangle yeah i love the wall
yeah
so okay so here's what happened we had
our own solar system before 1995 we were
the only known solar system
and so we presume that we be
representative of other solar systems
because we got to start somewhere let's
assume that we start discovering other
planets beginning in 1995
and the method
favored the discovery of big planets
even if there were little ones there
waiting to be seen
and what we found were that there were
jupiter-sized planets
orbiting really close to their host star
and we said who ordered that jupiter's
belong out you know way out where our
jupiter is
how did that happen and we kept looking
and there they were and they kept
showing up and they kept showing up and
so
we had to ask
what what's going on what is normal i
guess is how you hit this what is normal
and we went back to the
the formation drawing board and we
noticed
that in a solar system
you could start out with many times more
planets than you actually end up with
because some planets are orbits are
unstable
and what we mean by that is if you come
too close to a planet it can slingshot
you out
you can exit the star system
but by doing so it has consequences in
the solar system itself
so for every planet that gets flung out
the remaining planets readjust in their
position and there's a it's a whole
migrational thing going on in the solar
system it's called planet migration
and
planets can move in planets can move out
it depends on the circumstances of
what's going on here so
if you have a jupiter that's far out
we can imagine that the exchanges of
energies and the capturing of other
objects can
force that kind of readjustment to give
you the spread of what we actually see
in our catalogs of star systems so
that's what's going on there and in fact
i get to do this because this is star
talk the start talk book and and boy
reads right we have a reader in the
house
yeah our recent book on star talk cosmic
queries
there's a whole section
on the formation of star systems and
this migratory process
so so i invite you to to check out that
book it's a fun book and it's published
by national geographic mike drive what
look at this
this is why scott you you you come you
come well-read you're gonna get a
well-read response that's what you're
gonna get all woven together it's all
it's all tight tight answers
tight and it's got a sponsorship
attached to it i mean this is
this is how you make podcasts it's a
beautiful book and
it was um
one of our engineers and and editors and
and producers lindsay walker was a major
pro a contributor to that just making it
shape give start talkifying the content
to make sure that any star talk fan
feels like they are at home in that book
and so
so we got this i love it i i i admit i'm
embarrassed i've never heard of
planetary migration before yeah well
so you need a life
you got to get out more jordan that's
what i told you without any family or
friends just as this egg who was birthed
under the world i'm i'm still grasping
at frost yeah there you go
uh
paul love he's got a question for us he
says when we say that the universe is
expanding
are we really talking about just the
matter in the universe are we talking
about space time itself for example
during the rapid expansion the big bang
was it just all the matter in the
universe expanding into pre-existing
space
ooh
okay i can answer that
but only after we take a commercial
break
well done flip hanger you see what i did
there yeah it's classic i'm getting
better and better at that yeah this
one's really good make them wait
when we come back we're gonna find out
what the hell is the universe expanding
into and what does it mean even for it
to be expanding on star talk cosmic
queries
we're back cosmic queries star talk got
with me is my guest co-host jordan
clapper jordan love you man
right back at you neil love you all your
work and uh you still got the gig with
comedy central right and and uh
i'm still uh contributing to the good
old daily show right now so i i launch
out into the world every few weeks and
see what the world's talking about and
do you pitch stories to them or do they
request a view i do it's a little bit of
both we basically you know i have a
small little team that i tend to go out
uh to some of these rallies and events
with and we kind of watch the news and
when uh when a rally shows up or there's
a protest we went to a mass mandate
protest a few weeks ago there's a couple
events coming up we sort of look at
where the conversations go in and if
there's an event we try to get there and
talk to people and the more irrational
the conversation the more likely you
will be there to report it is exactly if
if you're like man i bet some people
have some uh irrational points of view
and are pretty angry about it the chance
i'm staying at a hotel now
all right so keep them coming we got
questions from our patreon members yes
so this is paul love's question he wants
to know when we say that the universe is
expanding are we talking about just the
matter in the universe are we talking
about space time yeah so so
this is what we learned from
general theory of relativity einstein
that
space which we think of as this empty
thing and of course things can move
through space earth is moving in orbit
around the sun through space the sun is
orbiting the center of the galaxy it's
moving through space
and there are some there's some galactic
motion where they're moving through
space however
underneath all of that is the fabric of
the space-time continuum
that is what's expanding when we speak
of the expanding universe
and so no the expanding universe and we
see galaxies hurtling away from each
other
they are being carried along
in the fabric
of the space-time continuum
and by the way that means in the early
universe there's no rule against
that fabric
stretching really
faster than the speed of light itself
the speed of light speed limit
is a restriction on how fast you can
move through space
not how fast space itself can expand so
the entire early universe it is booking
that is it is going way faster than the
speed of light not a problem
not a problem there
it is
when i'm visualizing this and using even
the term fabric should i be thinking of
it in that sense something that is
literally being
yeah i think
another way to fabric is a little more
poetic rather than just rubber sheet
the rubber sheet yeah the rubber sheet
makes me think of uh sixth grade and the
difficulties i had at night after i had
a big cola before going to bed oh is
that right oh gotcha gotcha
um
the
uh so is this the is this the first you
admit this of your childhood i think you
i think it's coming out i i want to be
open with everyone we clearly we have
readers here we have readers i want to
be honest with readers normally i'm
talking to people who haven't read a
book i'm talking to people read books
here's the deal sometimes people pee in
the middle of the night and it's okay
as long as you have uh
the fabric of the universe underneath
i gotta say that's that's a good
branding right there startup branded
fabric of the universe uh rubber sheets
for bed wetters yeah yeah there you go
so you have a rubber sheet and it
distorts when you sort of press it as a
mass would do to it
pressing down and and if you moved along
that rubber sheet you might sort of fall
in towards that
depression where the mass is and that's
kind of what things do when they're
moving through the pre-existing universe
the point is if you take that rubber
sheet and draw galaxies on it and then
just take it and stretch it then all the
galaxies are
are
moving away
from one another
as part of the embedded
rubber sheet that we're talking about
now here's here's the part that's that's
harder for our limited eight brains ape
brains to process
this stretching rubber sheet with these
dimples in it
is happening in three dimensions
so it's a three-dimensional stretching
rubber sheet with galaxies embedded in
it and it's and since time is a factor
here it's actually there's a fourth
dimension in it as well
so that's why by the way so let's take a
balloon they didn't ask this but it
rounds it out take a balloon
and draw galaxies on it and then you
inflate the balloon
okay so the balloon gets bigger and
bigger bigger and all the galaxies are
getting farther and farther apart from
each other then you say point to where
the universe began
every place you point
on the surface of the balloon
no place you point on the surface of the
moon gets you to the beginning
because the beginning is back through
time
you got to go through the fabric go back
through time to when all the balloon was
in the same place at the same time
so basically everywhere is the beginning
of the universe
14 billion years ago
well clear as mud
i was gonna
you know i it was the rubber bed sheet i
was getting somewhere my brain was
really starting to make sense of the
balloon i like that metaphor and but now
i'm moving through space and time i'm
seeing an exploded balloon and uh well
here so
when i came up in the ranks educators
were attempting
to go one dimension higher than the
rubber sheet and they talk about raisins
in a raisin cake
raisins and a raisin cake oh
as that it can okay
so as the cake expands
when you bake it the raisin the distance
between the raisins are
or increasing the problem there is the
raisin cake has an edge to it
okay
and whereas the surface of the balloon
has no edge
i mean also one of the other problems is
raisin cakes have fallen out of favor
you're not gonna you're not gonna find
yourself with a razor cake like until
you can connect it to a cronut
and have a hard time for the uh you know
nobody makes raisin cakes anymore
it's just not a thing
it's because you have to understand the
fourth dimension what time means to a
raisin cake and people like i'm kids
these days are too dumb to eat raisin
cake
uh
that's why it fell out of favor
that's what
kids aren't smart enough to eat them
uh this is from tyler pitts
hey new patro patron here excited to
join the family my question is about
dark matter
we have no clue what it is but what are
your speculations on what it could be
and what is the possibility of us
interacting with it anytime soon could
it be that dark matter is the material
slash matter of the void that our
universe is expanding into outside the
observable universe just the thing
that's been on my mind thank you guys
and all the love for michigan that's my
that's my home stage it's a lot of love
is that right cool that's right michigan
in the house
what's your hometown kalamazoo michigan
right
there home of derek jeter and jordan
clapper
people really know one of those names
[Laughter]
all right uh so
uh so we're talking about
talking about dark matter dark matter uh
what it what it could what it really
could be this is what i want it to be
but there's what i really think it
probably is
all right
so i'll tell you what it probably is
it's probably a class of particles
yet to be discovered
that has a very
low probability of interacting with our
class of particles
electrons protons neutrons and even our
light okay light is one of photons are
part of our particle family and so we
have our particle family and there may
be a whole other particle family that
just simply doesn't interact but if it
has mass it will have gravity and we see
the gravity
of the dark matter that's why
that's why we're calling it dark matter
okay it's matter and it's gravity
eighty-five percent of the universe's
gravity comes from it but it's
coexisting with us
by not interacting and that sounds kind
of weird doesn't it that sounds like
thanksgiving you're describing
thanksgiving it's
families co-existing but not interactive
there's no real
connection there right no connection
the chances of them connecting are
pretty low yeah american thanksgiving
got it okay we need uh who's the guy who
painted thanksgiving and all those other
american images um norman rockwell
normal rockwell so he needs we need an
updated
thanksgiving painting
we're people
screaming at each other yeah i think
it's a triptych of three of people as
far away as they can be and and carnage
in the middle
so
um
so what was that talking about now
you're talking about that's how you
imagine dark matter that's how you hope
dark matter exists or that's what you
how you think better exists so
so it's not a stretch to imagine two
things not interacting all right
for example
uh why do you have windows
in your home
the windows are transparent
to visible light
okay
now it turns out the light does interact
with the window it interacts with photos
and keeps moving through coherently but
what i'm saying is you have windows that
are transparent to visible light they're
not transparent to infrared
and how do i know that because you could
take a candle
or match and light it on one side of the
window and bring your hand right up to
the other side of the window and you
will not feel the heat
whereas you can see the match
so the visible light comes through the
window the infrared doesn't we live in a
world
of
non-interacting phenomenon
all right and we exploit that fact
all right you have us uh probably a
smartphone on your hip or on your desk
right now and if someone's calling you
it will ring
where did that signal come from it came
through your walls
okay okay
you could be in the in a windowless
bathroom and your phone will ring
because microwaves pass through all of
that
not interacting until it hits your phone
then it interacts
so we have built our lives
to interact with and not interact with
certain forms of energy
and that's all the same family of energy
so
let me keep going there's a particle
called the neutrino once again is part
of our family neutrino hardly interact
with anything oh my gosh
you need
in order to to detect a neutrino you
need like a a column of lead light years
long and then send the neutrino through
that and maybe it'll stop somewhere in
the lead cylinder
that's our own family of particles
so
we are imagining other families of
particles out there that
interact with us less than even the
stuff that we don't interact with
as part of our own family that's the
that's the over under on on what dark
matter is and we've got top people
searching for those particles right now
because if
we're hoping that it's not just that
they never interact they just
rarely interact so that maybe if you
have an experiment big enough and an
experiment lasts long enough they'll
have one one encounter where the dark
matter interacts with our matter and
then we would have experimental evidence
of its existence
we're working on that we got top people
working on that now my favorite
explanation
is that there's a parallel universe
that has more gravity than we do and
it's spilling into our universe
affecting the movement of our objects
and we're trying to it's like you know
the elephant what am i touching here
what is it we're touching the dark
matter oh it must be something i don't
know but it's regular matter and regular
gravity spilling out of an adjacent
universe that's what i want it to be
because that's simple that's the
simplest explanation
yeah and i mean it's the most fun
definitely that that that if uh
if that's a world that is beamed into my
netflix uh i'm watching season two
jumping back you're sticking with that
one
with that one
and and by the way i i'm not just making
this up
in a parallel universe if you look at
the properties
of these phenomena light cannot escape
the confines of a universe but the force
of gravity can it turns out
and i didn't take enough
quant quantum field theory or field
theory in general
to fully understand why that's so but
i've been told this by people
who do know this and who are experts in
field theory they tell me that the
properties of gravity allow it to leak
out of your universe
and even though the light can't so
you're not going to be able to see the
other universe but you might be able to
feel it i'm imagining like a muffin top
like it's spilling it out oh yeah oh i
like that all right give me another one
what do you have this is this is from
scott w peterson
why have car antennas gotten so much
smaller over the years
uh the wavelengths of the radio
frequency hasn't changed oh very i'd
love man we got good people out there
this is not a trash group oh man so far
from it this is a well-read
outside-the-box speakers
oh okay okay so
here we go
the uh first of all you don't see car
antennas anymore
and even when they first started going
away it's because they put the wires in
the window or in the
in the body of the car so i remember my
first car that had no antenna there was
a pair of wires that were embedded in
the
windshield glass that came up the middle
and then parted out left and right and
those were the
the radio antennas back when we were
receiving radio signals okay and so
the am radio
uh it's a long wavelength and it would
you generally you want an antenna
approximately the length of the
wavelength okay
today most of our communication is
microwaves
okay when you get satellite radio that's
all microwaves all of that microwave
waves are much smaller than radio waves
that's why they were called micro waves
to begin with
all right a microwave is about a
centimeter long
and so that's how you're doing your
communicating that's the all you need
that's why walkie-talkies never had big
antennas
like the old cars or even the um who
else had big antennas back i guess i
never knew the antennas were reflective
of the actual size of the wave correct
you want the antenna to kind of match
all right and if it doesn't match it
perfectly that's okay you'll get a some
percent of the radio signal getting
absorbed so we're cool with that and so
so
and nowadays of course everything's
coming over the internet or in other
ways but microwave is the primary way
that these things are are obtained now
there was a trick that they performed
and you might see this in some old-timey
cars but not so as old as have the
antenna
if you take an antenna that's long and
just coil it
you coil it
then you st it's the the wave still
feels the length of the of the wire of
your antenna even though the antenna is
coiled
and so a coiled antenna gets
some of the signal that that if it were
uncoiled that it would get and that was
a way to not have stuff just sticking
out as you drove down the street
and so yeah
that that we transitioned through that
to then just change the damn wavelengths
so it just be easier people are tripping
over these accords i remember having one
that my little uh my little radio player
by my bed when i was a kid that just it
just had a cord that was all the way
down and it was a
it was a big mess to be played out yeah
yeah okay
yeah so that was a great question yeah
yeah
uh this is from fernando gomes
uh greetings from brazil and yes neil i
read your letter to my country oh he did
yes i wrote a letter to to brazil a few
months ago just not to people
to the country
the country of brazil
it sounds like they got it to the
country that's what
what what was the letter to the country
of brazil you know okay so it was i oh i
remember i one of my books letters from
an astrophysicist was being translated
into portuguese in brazil
and they said do you mind writing a
letter to the portuguese people as a
just to welcome them to this book to
this translated book and i thought about
i said i don't want to write it to
people because people are so divisive
and things let me write it to something
that's not going to complain something
that can't say anything
so i said i wrote a letter to brazil and
that letter that it leads off the
brazilian translation of it and it's
it's a celebration of all that we in
america know in the united states know
of brazil and things that maybe they can
and be more proud of brazil had early
pioneers in aviation for example uh the
very first uh latin uh
south american astronaut was brazilian
okay for example so they have they have
a an and and
uh most airplanes that you ride between
medi medium-sized cities in the united
states
are designed
and built
in brazil
right embraer is a brazilian
aerospace company
and so we you know we we tend to think
of brazil as people with not much
clothes on on the beach
and we think of coffee and maybe soccer
right
and so i as a scientist wanted to make
sure that all the rest of what brazil
has been and represents and can still
represent doesn't get forgotten and so
it's a celebration
of a country all it has been and all it
can be
look at that
this is so if i want you to write me a
lovely letter like that do i have to
convince you to write it to like the
borough of brooklyn instead
is that where you live that's what i was
going to say yeah you come on i'm i'm
dying for a lovely thoughtful letter
from neil but i guess he has to envision
me as a a city state or at least a
borough so
um uh well i want to get to fernando's
question neil but uh let's take a break
first okay sure so we'll be right back
star talk cosmo aquarius
so jordan
we're back we left off we were we were
on the beaches of brazil last i checked
it was nice the weather was nice it was
a good vibe
did mr gomes what was his question did i
answer his question fernando wanted to
thank you but he also did have one
question no he did okay
i'm gonna throw it out here he wondered
is it possible for the dark energy
phenomenon a phenomenon aka space-time
expansion
to be an emergent property of matter
itself only manifesting in bigger scales
like little ants don't look very complex
themselves so they can show interesting
behaviors when you observe the colony as
a whole once again a highly literate
question coming it's a scientifically
literate question i love it so let me
just
unpack something there he mentioned
emergence emergence is a
relatively recent exploration
going on in the field of biology all
right i think we've always known about
it but we hadn't really thought as
deeply about it as we have in recent
decades so emergencies you can look at a
bird
snatch a pigeon off the fountain right
which we don't recommend star trek does
not recommend this is a theoretical
conversation thank you thank you very
much i got lawyers in my ear nails so
you got you grab a pigeon
and then study it
all you can and all you want
right on down to its molecular
makeup okay so it's got a brain a beak
eyes it can lay eggs if it's a girl
pigeon instead of a boy pigeon it's got
feathers it can fly you figure all this
out
we don't yet know
what's going on in the pigeon
for it to know
that there are occasions where a bunch
of them take flight simultaneously and
then flock together as they fly
so the flocking of birds
is emergent
because it's something you can't
deduce
from studying a single bird
and knowing practically everything maybe
there's something in the brain that we
haven't gotten to yet the neuroscience
of pigeons that's probably lower on the
list than the neuroscience of humans
maybe we'll get there eventually but
emergent behavior are things that the
the some of the the parts themselves
are not concerned with
don't concern themselves with it but the
collection of parts together
have a property
that has emerged and consciousness human
consciousness is considered one of those
things could it be
that once you have a sufficiently
complex brain
does consciousness just emerge
and so yeah these are very deep so is
dark energy an emergent feature
of the universe and gravity and space i
don't know it's kind of cool to think
that right
and
but it would be weird to say
matter which attracts itself
has an emergent feature that repels
itself
that's just kind of i don't know how to
walk into a room and say that
um
confidently
so no it's an interesting thought and i
love the concept of emergence and it
shows up in all kinds of ways and places
among us a tangential question you you
talk about pigeons what is it about
pigeons i know there's stories of tesla
uh befriending a pigeon and that being
one of them tesla the car or tesla the
human being the human being uh nikolai
the cars the cars i don't know i'm not
i'm not rich enough to know what the
cars make friends with uh
but i know the human being uh was buddy
buddy with a pigeon for my uh he spent
his late later years in new york city in
a hotel in midtown
and i heard rumors that you know through
the open window because pigeons or
pigeons and cities go together right
yeah and actually they're i think
they're technically called rock doves
and they thrive in canyons with steep
sides that have rocks and that's
precisely what modern cities are that
have tall buildings so pigeons are right
at home with our civilization and so if
you feed them in a windowsill they'll
come back i don't have all the story
there about tesla's later years but i
just know the physics that he
contributed to in his earlier years i
love thinking of them as rock dubs
yeah yeah
i mean flying rats i've heard before
it feels like a pejorative they've never
done anything to me so i'm gonna
uh
i got a question from david peterson
here he wants to know neil
i was hoping you might be able to offer
your opinion on what you think we would
see if we traveled at the speed of light
i've thought about this quite a bit i
was wondering mostly if there would be a
redshift in what would be seen
yeah so since you can't actually travel
the speed of light this let's do the
next best thing and travel 99.99999
the speed of light okay and oh by the
way
there's an author a brilliant physicist
and popularizer
named george gamov
g-a-m-o-w
[Music]
the w pronounced as a v
george gamov
and he he wrote mid-century last i one
of my favorite books ever was written by
him it's called one two three infinity
still on my shelf read it in middle
school and it's a brilliant exposition
of science and math and really cool
topics so
in there
he
uh
not in that book but he wrote a series
of books called mr tompkins
the mr tompkins series and this is he mr
tompkins
uh
i think that the root name of the series
is mr tompkins in wonderland but
is it wonderland no that's allison
wonder
i'm getting my my my fictional worlds
mixed up but it's definitely mr tompkins
and he
goes into worlds where the
constants of the laws of physics are
different
and one of the stories is the speed of
light
is
60 miles an hour or like 100 something
where you're in a car
and you can approach the speed of light
just as as a as a regular joe doing so
and when you do that he then describes
what you see and how things get
distorted and and so i i highly
recommend the whole mr tompkins series
because it's um it's it brings exotic
phenomenon of physics into your everyday
life experience
now so
if you go very fast
near the speed of light the light
sources in front of you become basically
blue shifted they have higher energy
than you would otherwise measure them to
have and if you look behind you
everything has lower energy so there's
this focusing in front of you
where everything in front of you becomes
brighter and brighter and brighter
and the if you trap if you follow the
light trajectories
the the ray it's called ray tracing you
follow what the light does
it actually narrows your field of view
ahead of you so in star wars they make
the jump to hyperspace all right and
that's their word for hitting light
speed and they did the visual on that
first and it's not perfectly accurate
but you get a sense of this
uh focusing of light energy that's
sitting in front of you that is what
happens as you speed up and go close to
the speed of light and in in star trek
of course they call it warp speed that
would be uh the speed of light for them
and then when they hit the star trek
movie which came after star wars they
did that light
effect as well so now that's just a
standard uh standard operating procedure
for the visual effects people yeah it's
a number four i think
yeah so it's fun and i recommend that
series check it out and you'll learn
more about other
things that can be different when you
change the constants of nature
i got a question here from tamara
michael
do you think we will ever be able to
develop dark matter vision goggles that
will work in outer space similar to
night vision goggles on earth
i love it yeah i love it so if we figure
out the dark matter is a certain kind of
particle and we figure out how to detect
it
that's the thing something can be there
but what good is it if you can't then
capture it and then do something with it
all right i mean think about it before
we discovered radio waves
we were bombarded by radio waves by the
sun but we had no way to even know that
was happening because they pass right
through us until we figured out how to
make a radio wave detector
now we can aim it where we want detect
it and then process it and then we fully
exploited that and turned it into music
and tv and everything else so
if once we figure out what dark matter
is and how to detect it i don't see why
we can't flip up some dark matter
goggles and then look and look at the
grander of dark matter in the universe
that would be beautiful
tamara has actually one more additional
question here that uh that is
fascinating she wants to know why do we
think
we know anything about the outer galaxy
if we could only see back in time as we
look further away couldn't everything we
see and or think we know be drastically
different by now if there is light but
mandy's a good question these are good
if there's life on other distant planets
would we ever really know unless we
actually go there okay so this is great
this is i'm loving it i'm tickled by it
we got
these are my people
these trash people are good people you
know the trash bin the question transfer
the trash bin folks what what a great
crew they got they got the smartest
questions of them all okay
so it's a smart trash bin that's all
it's a smart trash bit yeah
so
first it's a brilliant question
and we ask that of ourselves in the
professional scientific community every
now and then
and here's what gives us the confidence
because it is true the only thing of the
universe that we know is happening now
is what's going on
right under our noses here on earth
when we look to the moon whatever's
going on in the moon happened
one and a half seconds ago
okay we look at the sun that happened
eight minutes and 20 seconds ago
if some giant plucked the sun out of the
solar system in this instant
we would still feel the sun we could
still see the sun we'd still be orbiting
the sun and we would do so for another
eight minutes and 20 seconds
and as you go farther out
these objects are coming to us from
farther and farther in our past
so watch what we do
we look in our laboratories that's
happening now
and we measure the speed of light the
values of the quantum constants like
planck's constant thing we measure what
elements do when they're heated when
they make spectra we get all of these
physical properties and we have books
with these properties in them
then we look out a little ways
okay
uh how about to the outer solar system
how about the planet uranus
how does this war oh it's orbit is not
following newton's laws oh my gosh okay
we found the limit there's a limit in
space forget time there's a limit in
space
where the law doesn't apply oh wait a
minute
uranus is being tugged on by neptune
neptune hadn't been discovered yet so we
discovered neptune oh my gosh so now
that we factor that in it is following
newton's laws
oh wait a minute so there are two stars
out there farther away than the planets
and they're orbiting each other
bam they're following newton's laws
okay
this is cool let's look farther out in
the galaxy let's look to other galaxies
oh my gosh the spectrum made by carbon
and oxygen and nitrogen matches exactly
the spectrum we have for it here on
earth
oh my gosh so
as we inched our way out
we tested whether the phenomenon we're
observing matches the
phenomenon that we've established with
properties that we've established here
on earth in the here and the now and in
fact they do and it applies not only
across space
but through the depths of time to the
beginning of the cosmos and that's why
science works at all
if it just changed everywhere
willy-nilly then the science would only
be good like here on earth and nowhere
else
but we got this one and it was not a
given people say oh science has faith
that or not we have measurements that
tell us this then that's why we proceed
with confidence going forward
boom
boom what i'm impressed the people who
live on the sun which we'll get into a a
next episode are going to hear that they
live on the dark side of the sun they
live on the dark side of the sun
it's going to be in 8 minutes and 40
seconds they're going to have some
knowledge drop on them
i haven't thought about that
they don't even know what's coming they
don't know what's coming
so jordan dang i think we ran out of
time on this one but thanks for coming
in for this
and we're going to continue to watch you
on on comedy central and i get to say
every time you have a segment i know
that guy like and he knows my name
that's how i feel i still have the
degrasse part i have a hard time
pronouncing uh
degrassi uh but i you know but other
than that you you're totally correct yes
i love being on here neil i'm neil
degrasse tyson your personal
astrophysicist as always bidding you to
keep looking up
[Music]